Dakota Johnson gets a super suggestive
on social media look at me oh yeah the
Fifty Shades of Grey star just wrapped
filming on the series and seems she's
missing the set and all her steamy
scenes the 26 year old posted this pic
to Instagram um yeah you can see where
her hand is placed there and she
captioned it I'll have an order of
identity crisis with a side of what's my
hand doing Dakota has spent the last
several months filming sex scenes almost
non-stop she and Jamie Dornan shot the
second and third movies in the franchise
back to back in April she joked with
interview magazine I've been simulating
sex for seven hours straight right now
and I'm over it
well maybe not as over it as she thought
but those scenes can be exhausting
Dakota toll DT sex scenes especially for
Fifty Shades are a lot of work they're
really technical and and really
choreographed because it has to be safe
and also like done the right way and
there are a lot of rules and things you
need to do the right way in order to
stay true to the BDSM subcultures
you